on n'est pas frustré en collection c'est
la fantasmagorie inconsciente c'est le
noyau et vous nicolas et bouddhique oh
là bas moi mon couple mythique serait il
adviendrait uniquement si je me
réconcilie avec moi même nom ça démarre
par un nicolas vous avez fait quoi vous
souhaitez voir moi en fait j'ai beaucoup
dormi et j'ai pour réarranger toutes les
plumes et lumière ah oui mais chez vous
j'habite dans un endroit où il n'y a pas
de fenêtre
non c'est vrai oui way to merveilleux
rideau d'ailleurs sont rouverts maman
dracula ouais ouais je suis tout le
temps donc tout le temps dans le dos
dans le noir au noir ah oui disons n'y a
pas la lumière du soleil mais quoi il
n'y a pas de fenêtre chez vous non mes
preuves ou les halles effet obstrué où
on ne vient pas dire il y en a pas vous
avez trouvé un appartement il n'y a pas
de fenêtre
non mais vous habite en sous-sol tient
sous sol aussi nous habitons mute dans
le métro non non au rez-de-chaussée me
amadeus away et ça vous dire c'est que
vous cherchez en fait moi j'aime bien
c'est vraiment cool entre dracula en
fait avant les grands rideaux fermés et
baron larrey
après j'ai des milliards de lé en fait
que je ajouter positionne suivant mes
humeurs daimler est remonté hier c'est
vrai que mon harnais laporte tranquille
mais des formidables
oui ben oui et c'est vraiment nicolas
c'est le dernier rockeur voiture soit
vraiment mais vraiment le vrai ça va le
mettre
fumito non non c'est pas ça se jette sur
un canapé avec une bière pour l'argent
vous auriez suis allée nager parce que
le milieu aquatique et mon milieu avec
moi aussi ma mémoire vous me lâcher
aquaboulevard je suis dans la nuit à
moitié un batracien tour et je suis
aussi allé alors que l'aquarium du
trocadéro collection de mes 2
oui absolue magnifique china et alien
pâle aliens crystal palace et apathique
il ya deux bien sûr le film exactement
ces lancements vous êtes dans loin dans
le film dans les six réacteurs est donc
voilà la piscine à vagues
c'est vrai je pense que quand on est
follement amoureux ouais on ne voit
qu'une personne ou le dur pour cette
personne on penser le monde
l'appréhension du monde dès que pour
cette personne c'est une focalisation
une cristallisation absolue donc les
autres n'existent n'existe pas nicolas
la convergence du des défis actuels dans
un couple idéal faut qu'elle soit
parfaite
c'était quand on est excité par la même
chose d'accord il peut pas y avoir un
fidélité dans le sens où il y aurait par
exemple des limites données de chaque sa
part et que ce qui est au centre suffit
à l'épanouissement des deux et donc il
n'y aurait pas de question d'aller voir
ailleurs
c'est en fait si on est dans les mêmes
là on n'est pas frustré en sélection
c'est la fantasmagorie inconscient c'est
le noyau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très important de la convergence
des fantasmes si ces vidéos ont les
mêmes fantasmes et que ça leur convient
ils peuvent rester à vie ensemble assez
sa cause causse de nicolas et d'ariel
franchement c'est un personnage
j'adore je suis très heureux de les voir
nicolas jean bouche je sente nicolas
champ sans les choses avant qu'on passe
au top 3 des infos du jour
est ce que vous pensez qu'il peut se
passer quelque chose entre francesca et
mathieu ça vous coûte rien dire oui
d'après ce que j'ai cru comprendre
monsieur est plutôt portée sur les
hommes
ah oui vous avez bien compris mais bon
je vais vous dire oui à à penser qu'il
pourrait se passer quelque chose dans
les bennes nicolas il est très fort
nicolas chez moi j'ai une confiance en
lui je sentis 112 et rigole pas et vous
la connaissez beaucoup d'avant on
connaissait d'avant non je me sens et de
vinyles à 1 foot est de 20 ah oui c'est
vrai que vous auriez sorte de ya
introduit domestique très très agréable
et très tôt et ensuite ça peut se faire
une vie sexuelle ça va ailleurs et sans
éclat une vidéo estime se soulagera
gougoux tous les deux c'est étonnant
elle se trouvait la même chose avec ses
rides et moi non en place des assiettes
briser contre les murs
[Musique]